i think it's undeniable
every every film
every story
has
that moment
what is your writing process
as i mentioned i have ideas rattling in
my head
when i decide that i want to work on
something the first thing that i do is i
get a composition notebook uh usually
like one of those black and white
speckled notebooks
uh and that's a holdover from junior
high uh my writing teacher that's what
she made us
you know we had to get the black and
white speckle notebook that's where all
of
our assignments you know we did them in
that notebook
so that's just stuck with me to this day
um
i get a notebook
write the working title
on the cover
and on the first page first page is
reserved for the title and character
names
uh i usually start with the protagonist
right
once i've got that notebook
every idea every thought that i have
about this story goes into that notebook
there's no real rhyme or reason i don't
you know aside from the first page i
don't have say like a section for
dialogue or anything like that you know
i just everything that i've been
thinking goes into that notebook
if i go out to have lunch or whatever
and something hits me that i think would
be perfect
i come back and i put in that notebook
um
once i have kind of like
all the notes and everything
i craft my outline
my outlines are not too detailed you
know they're pretty spare
and this is because
once i have the outline i start writing
the story
really really like develops it really
begins to tell itself
you know i've got my notes i've got the
outline i know what's supposed to happen
but it blossoms during the writing
process so i like to you know keep
things loose the outline is like you
know very spare
and i mean that's pretty much it you
know i write
i can't
write out of order
i'm not one of those writers i know a
lot of people that
say oh if a scene is hard for you
you know just
write tktk and come back to it i can't
do that i have to work it out in that
moment and if i'm not able to work it
out in that moment then that's where i
stop for the day and when i come back to
it the next day or whatever let's give
it another go
and um and yeah that's that's pretty
much my process and i mean that's that's
for my my books as well
you know um all of my books same thing
get the notebook
write the characters throw in whatever
notes
outline it
and then
write
and are you reading
the new work
from the day before like are you going
through the entire thing of what you've
written or you're just starting from the
scene right about where you're going to
start up again yeah i just start from
the scene the thing is i know the story
by the time i start writing the actual
script i know the story so well i don't
have to review the previous day's pages
or you know
start from scratch i don't have to do
any of that i just jump in
at the at the scene and i keep going
um
and then once the script is finished
then you know of course i go back and i
read from the beginning and see
um and usually things things work out i
mean there may be some things that i'd
have to shift or you know whatever maybe
there's a payoff that
you know didn't have a setup and so i
may need to include that or whatever but
for the most part
you know because i know the story so
well i can just jump right in and
and then um when you finished the
screenplay do you give it some time
before you go in and look at okay
definitely definitely you know it's the
old put it in the drawer don't think
about it
um
i don't even give it to people to read
at that point you know i just let it sit
and
get to work on the next idea and then i
pull it out and you know once i pull it
out you know after some time that's when
i'll give it to readers you know because
it's kind of fresh for everyone if that
makes sense so
get the feedback from my readers and you
know i've given it time giving it some
distance and it's just like okay
i also find out more receptive to um
to getting like feedback and notes
because that time has passed and i'm a
little bit removed from it you know
because when you're you know i've just
finished it you know it's my baby
if i get notes back right away
saying oh you know perhaps you should
consider this it's like no this is my
how dare you this is my baby but with
time and you know
it's like all right that makes sense
you know more receptive to uh to the
feedback
have you ever given it to someone and
you
decided that was the wrong person to
give it to
oh that happens often that happens often
but but i find more often than not that
happens if i give it to someone who's
perhaps not in the industry someone
who's
knows nothing about screenwriting or
they're not as invested in storytelling
i like to do that just because i want to
get i want to get an outsider's
perspective you know i just i just want
to know what you know
joe the common man who you know thinks
about about this script
um
but yeah yeah that that that does happen
that does happen from time to time
also too so many people consuming films
they're not in the industry right right
right and and so
in some sense if it can appeal to
the person the working person in another
state not in the industry right and that
i mean yeah that's that's a large part
of why i do it because you know for
instance i sent my buddy ralph i sent
him a copy of
my recent work in progress
because i imagined him as the everyman
taking his wife to the movies on a
friday night you know it's date night
what do you think of this you know so
that's exactly why you give it to people
who
aren't also screenwriters or
you know in the industry
can you explain how you outline a
screenplay it's
not uh yeah sure i mean it's not uh like
an in-depth process or anything i
literally
write uh um each scene out
you know just like
a line describing each scene
right
i don't even number
the scenes i just draw a star with a
circle around it that's how i know okay
new scene and i write what's supposed to
happen and it's usually just like a line
or two because as i mentioned
in the actual writing of the script the
scene blossoms it comes to life uh
things happen so i don't get too
detailed it's just
what's supposed to happen
and
yeah i you know i don't i don't aim for
a set number of scenes i know some
people
oh you know 70 70 scenes and you have a
movie i think that's david lynch
who said something like that uh i'm not
an index card person i never have been
like that just doesn't work for me
i just
write the scenes down in my notebook
and go from there
why do you love save the cat
save the cat
provides
structure
uh
and i do like structure i know
you know based on what i said like about
the outline it might not seem like i'm
too but i do like structure
and
the thing about save the cat when i when
i read it
it was so funny i found save the cat um
this guy was selling books
randomly like on the street
and uh it i mean you see that a lot uh
in new york at least uh someone will
have something set up and i was walking
past and you know just looking at what
he's selling you selling books and cds
and stuff and i saw save the
cat and i'd heard of it but i hadn't
read it
and i asked him okay how much you know
for for this book he's like a dollar i
remember it's like a dollar that's like
you've got a deal
so i give him a dollar and i take save
the cap and i read it
and
i understood why it kind of
riled some people up
but again it provides structure like
i don't think that you have to be
you don't have to be beholden to like
what it says you don't have to treat it
as as gospel right you don't have to
have a certain event happen on a certain
page or whatever but recognize that
these elements
are pretty much in every film and you
know we see in every script that we read
if you're looking to
as i am
write commercial feature films
it's not a bad guy to follow it's not
you know
um
and so that's that's i mean that's
honestly that's why
and
i think it's undeniable
every every film
every story
has
that moment that catalyst that shakes up
the protagonist's world every every
story has that moment where the the
character debates
as to what they should do
i feel like every story has like that
save the cat moment it might not come at
the very beginning but there's that
moment that
you realize the protagonist more often
than not is someone you want to root for
there's always a dark night of the soul
there there always is
you know
um
so yeah
save the cat
it laid the structure out for me and it
gave me the terms because i didn't you
know i didn't know what
all these terms you know we're called
but
it lays it out and i think it's it's i
think it's brilliant
and even sid field sid field did
something similar i mean in screenplay
you know he's okay you've got
your first second and third act and then
you've got your plot point a and your
plot point b and he had page numbers but
you don't have to
stick to those page numbers just know
that those elements are should be
present those elements should be present
you should include them
you